I was probably 12 or 13 I was having a
tantrum about something you know I'm
tall my mother's a smaller woman she's
probably 5'2 or 5'3 and I'm six feet
tall obviously take after my father who
was a big very big man and and I'm you
know I'm having that tantrum like I
can't believe you didn't do this and she
said um she said do you think I'm a my
mind reader if you want something you
ask for it and for whatever reason I can
see her face I thought that that made
such good logical sense to me she you
know it stopped cold and through my life
I've I've reflected back on that where
there are times I think in your
professional career and those of you
who've already had the career now you're
back at MBA school and and you'll go
back out um I think sometimes we're
reluctant or we think gosh I'm a great
performer they're GNA just notice me
that just doesn't really happen um it it
really doesn't and you can't be you know
you don't want to be a bragger or you
know you want to have humility but you
can't be shy to make clear to your
supervisors your leaders whomever what
your aspiration is what your ambition is
to to achieve otherwise people aren't
going to just guess um nobody I promise
you cares more about your career than
you do